hier ist es absolut das absolute op
schwer sonst hab ich noch nie gesehen
hier guck mal durch die doppel sechs mal
ab da ist
servus kids und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video wir fallen direkt in
die runde rein denn wir spielen heute
wieder crazy world dem lucky blog modus
und mit dabei ist der skv leute und ich
habe heute auf den escada bei high und
zusammen werden heute für euch aufnehmen
ja na klar deklarieren kannst du diesen
modus schon mal vorgestellt weil la cage
aux ja ja ich habe ein paar mal gespielt
glaube ich einmal glaub ich in stream
video dreimal in bremen und einmal in
video
es könnte sogar stimmt nicht klar was
für ein scheiß aber es könnte wirklich
genau hin kommen mehr leute als os
funktion so man baut ihr die ärzte ab
tauscht die ärzte dann am ende der
wartezeit die da rechts abläuft gegen
waffen rüstungen alles möglich 91
institute gefunden oder gibts auch nicht
aber immerhin ein paar pfeile kann sich
sehen lassen
genau so funktioniert das zum beispiel
bekommt man für das merkte bekommt man
schwerter je mehr schwer es wagte man
hat desto mehr beste ist besseres wetter
bekommt man für gold bekommt man
rüstungen und auch gold äpfel oder
tränke so deswegen versuchen wir alles
ein bisschen mitzunehmen und das beste
was man überhaupt kriegen kann sind
player herz also ja die köpfe von
anderen spielern kriegt man wenn man sie
tötet genau und dann kann man sich
richtige europe lucky blogs für waffen
sonst aus genau da kann man sich dann
ich weiß gar nicht wie die genau heißt
aber dann kann man sich halt ins special
armer blog oder ein special weblog holen
da kann es passieren dass einen die jazz
mit protection drei feuerschutz drei
dropped oder ich hab ganz viel gesammelt
oder schwert mit schaffen es vier
jetzt hier bei diesen meint lucky blogs
passiert nicht so viel druck mainz dafür
gerade genauso da passiert nicht so viel
aber bei den special oder wie auch immer
die heißen die kann ich nach bestimmten
zeigen werden auf jeden fall markiert
machen würde ich sagen da passiert halt
einiges und deshalb auch nur noch nice
wenn das jetzt nur zusammentragen
ich habe zwölf smaragde da kann es auch
etwas abhaben ab 14
okay da habe ich immer dass das wieder
sport sport schule kennt es nicht okay
dann also grünen genau
kathrin groppe geht das motto angemerkt
kann jetzt sehen wir wollen ja genau
dann ihren schatten bot er ein baum auf
ein neuerliches fahrer richtig entfernte
schwerter bürgervereins dann kann ich
mir jetzt auch noch eine dj stolen alte
hose
also so viel 15 15
gold in der tat ok ich hole mir jetzt
engagiert ist und die feeling porsches
für dich sagen kosten all ihr gold aber
die brings ziemlich hier ist kriegt man
gar nicht merkt man gar nicht ob sie den
porsche sind hat op finde ich zumindest
so hast du schon bau ja noch einen job
bekommen überhaupt kann strings gingen
bau eintauschen weist oder ja ich hab
grad eingetroffen
ok also ja monatlich noch keinen zusatz
von wasser einmal hast du noch gold nähe
ich habe es genau passend in heiltränke
investiert sorry ich habe auch nur drei
also ich habe drei gold drei träger
bekommen da oben ist besteht auch eine
kiste wenn du ein reiterhof führt aber
okay willie walsh fallen die malls
fallen
ich will bestimmt einfach ab und gehen
volle kanne drauf so wo fallen die wall
street oder ich verliere dann geh doch
mal hier dann kann man es vielleicht
hinten an ihn von hinten anschleichen ja
damals rein das ist mit der einrüstung
genau so schön wie sie bald mit live aus
bei dir ja isio monat voll to be one
sehr schöne zeit versucht ihr tipps zu
geben
ok kurzem wusste bergab tauschen hast du
den player hat ja ich habe zwei player
hat sondern sie schon 132 betten zwei
rappen so forciert es hier also haben
jetzt hier den player head und tauschen
die gegen diese wetten lucky blogs die
platzieren wir jetzt und dann passieren
magische dinge transport der op zum
beispiel hier ein schwert mit
neuer vereins verbrennung 1 und das seit
2003 hat es ja erst mal auf dann kräftig
scherf und verbrennung mal zusammen
robert ich brauche ein paar level hast
du palette von borders dann hole ich mir
die kurz dann kann ich wieder richtig
packen op schwert machen
es war schärfe drei verbänden
verbrennung 1 hier schärfe zwei nächsten
moment mal
moment moment mal ach wie achate okay
das ist schärfer 1 dann brauche ich noch
ein chef eines red aber jetzt noch genug
als ok-chefin schärfer ins bett das
müsste funktionieren bei 800 watt und
welche ja sicher hatte kämpft kurz weg
ich muss aber ich habe mir einen weg
ich habe hier noch flexibler zu machen
an die ggg sie durch die durch ihr okay
hast du noch ein helm für mich juli
hatten schärfe vier schwerter das wird
richtig op es gleich passt mal auf wenn
ich jetzt hier schärfe 1 und das schärfe
zwei verbrennung 201 ja dann hab ich
jetzt hier mein anderes schärfer zwei
schwert oder wo ist das hellrot gefragt
was passiert damit drei tage später so
junger hirsch erfordert hier ist es
absolut das absolute op schwer sonst hab
ich noch nie gesehen hier guck mal durch
die doppel sechs mal ab da ist es so
fucking op älter schärfen 401
deaktiviert wenn ich will mal sagen wir
gehen jetzt in den nahkampf wurde aus
mainz würde ich auch sagen sich der wald
abbrennt sie wird einfach leute
zerstören was da oben auf dem baum ist
jemand oder nicht ist auch jemand warte
prozent hat uns ein hund controlling und
it leiter des unter gesprungen glaube
ich das noch rund 80
er ist hier ja warte ich hab den die am
boden oder immer die junge der frist
keine chance sage ich also wenn ihr
gegen die kommt jemand eine chance hat
dann will ich einen besen alter
es ist eine schärfe vier verbrennung ein
schwert und die leute kriegen es ins
gesicht
wunderbar wieder richtig geld das machte
sie durch sie durch zieht euch durch
oder geht update update ab ja okay so
wurde holmes würde ich sagen ja der geht
in die mitte alles quatsch zurück zurück
zurück zurück zurück warum sie kommen
durch die zombies bringt uns immer an
ich kann mich mit 1.0 aller exporte
alter.de geändert habe ihm aber in fire
eingedrückt ja er hatte keine chance
erkennen schaut der traun
3 herr ein harmonisches weg aber es gibt
immer noch gegner muss aufpassen
es gibt noch drei geografische der lava
alte 22 gold er für what the [ __ ] you
fucking op und wir haben auch mega viel
oder ich habe zumindest einen player hat
er nicht umtauschen kann habe noch
eingekauft wird sage ich dir mal auf
aber ganz ehrlich
ok schrift irgendwas mach da oben sind
sie als ob die da oben auf dem baum
schälen alter bücher mit zwei arten
lassen sich durch machen wir uns aber
hier in visp zeugen ermitteln ja was man
auf genau das ist ja noch ganz gut hier
da gibt es einmal die mega drops so
jetzt haben wir hier schutz drei
feuerschutz bekommen hast du noch player
hätte ich aber auch noch ein
ich hab jetzt auf jeden fall jede menge
pfeile ich habe ein starkes passt scho
würde ich sagen ich werde hier kein
bisschen auf arme gehen knapp 36 ist
nicht neu es ist nämlich jetzt auch mal
schutz drei feuerschutz drei wunderbar
ja es stimmt jetzt dr mega last affair
wie man wechseln orthaus kann jeder
kommen der die gemeinde mit rankin trank
der silberfisch soll dann gehen wir den
erstmal hier drüben müsse ich habe und
es sind drei session auf heming sehr
schön so und der nächste gegner ist hier
drüben lassen überhaupt wissen wir holen
musst du eigentlich wie ein kompass ja
klar zeigt jetzt in die richtung aber ob
ihm klar
drei teams leben noch 13 ist also
mindestens drei vier spieler mindestens
vier spieler noch kommst du da hoch dass
irgendwas im hochbau ich auch jetzt
gemacht
ich finde keine dort platzieren wo der
rückraummitte mithin keine ahnung da
oben ist auf einer damit ist allen damit
das andere ja die gar die fressen alle
so krass im keine chance ja und es soll
aber das la walter junger kannst dich
löschen gerade geschäft ja jetzt rennen
die boarder mit dem takt bringen wir
drücken den weg weg vom der frist so
hart junge wieder denkt aber das ist
stark jungen wieder denkt das ist so
krass wie macht ihr da ist es geht nicht
hacker chance junge der hack doch stars
wollen juni steht in der lava und
kassiert hits von zwei spielern niemals
geht das ja egal wie hat er das gemacht
hat
er konnte das andere nur sekunden kurz
zurück ziehen wirklich immer ein
grummeln antonia ich habe es nichts
gegeben und der andere ist auch die
junge warst du eine runde
leute wir haben jetzt einfach 7 kills
gemachten diese runde mit diesem fucking
op schwert das ist wirklich das leben
gerettet dankeschön max muss dabei sein
sondern sehr gerne runde
ich bin wieder das garantiert in köln
also lasst michael jackson war wenig
reibung fallen